y la agenda bilateral que fueron
discutidas entre el secretario de estado
de los eeuu anthony blinken y el
presidente de la república a bordo en
distintos temas en principio se habló
sobre la cooperación entre ambos países
a propósito de la pandemia y la
colaboración por parte de los eeuu a
favor de ecuador pero también otros
temas que se trataron como el
crecimiento económico acuerdos en
materia de gestión de deuda en los temas
migratorios en el calentamiento global
pero hubo temas donde él se hizo mayor
énfasis y específicamente también la
migración venezolana en el secretario de
estado de eeuu ha dicho de que la
situación venezolana requiere una
respuesta por parte de la comunidad
internacional y específicamente en este
tema aseguró deber de una resolución
política en venezuela en cuanto a la
mesa de diálogo también el secretario de
estado de los eeuu anthony blinken
expresó que lamentaba que la mesa de
diálogo por parte de
el grupo que representa a nicolás
podemos se levantará de la mesa de
diálogo y ha dicho físicamente que él
considera los eeuu consideran que han
prevalecido los intereses de álex sab en
en cuanto a no progresar los intereses
de los el pueblo venezolano también
ofreció algunos otros temas sobre la
extradición por parte de el señor alerta
hacia los eeuu
gustavo en otros temas hemos visto
imágenes de policías y militares
realizando requisas en las calles cuál
es la percepción que tiene la ciudadanía
sobre el estado de excepción
pero la percepción que tiene la
ciudadanía del estado de la sección es
positiva específicamente esto tiene que
ver en cuanto a el incremento de niveles
de criminalidad que existe en este
momento en ecuador pero también hay
otras reacciones mientras que la
ciudadanía valora positivamente que las
fuerzas armadas y la policía nacional
están haciendo operativos de seguridad
durante las 24 horas también hay otras
reacciones al estado de decisión por lo
menos hay sectores de los trabajadores
que cuestionan el estado de decisión
porque esto le permitiría la aprobación
por parte de la asamblea nacional de
proyectos eran presentados por parte del
ejecutivo pero también se valora de otra
manera por lo menos los sectores
indígenas y sectores de los trabajadores
cuestionan también este estado de cesión
porque están convocadas movilizaciones
en los próximos días mañana va a haber
una movilización se ha anunciado una
segunda movilización para el 26 de
octubre y hay sectores que rechazan este
estado de excepción porque estaría
relacionado con el control de las
movilizaciones en el país son distintas
percepciones de igual forma también
tiene que ver con la advertencia que ha
hecho el presidente de la república en
cuanto a la disolución de la asamblea
nacional este ha sido un fantasma que ha
manejado la opinión pública y cuanto las
advertencias que hizo sobre la que si no
se aprueban proyectos el eje enviado
ante la asamblea nacional el tendría el
decreto el listo de la disolución de la
asamblea nacional así que son distintas
percepciones del estado de sección